-A propos d'ovni,
je vous le disais tout à l'heure,
un ovni est au centre
du prochain film de Louis de Funès.
Enfin de Jean Girault, avec
Louis de Funès, Villeret et Carmet.
Un ovni qui nous amène sur terre
un petit homme vert
qui, décidément, aime beaucoup
la soupe aux choux,
d'où le titre du film.
En attendant la sortie de ce film,
pour le mois de novembre,
Louis de Funès a profité
du dernier week-end
pour rencontrer une partie
de ses spectateurs, les jeunes,
au salon de l'enfance.
L'occasion pour lui de bavarder avec
une partie importante de son public
et de répondre aux questions
que se posent les jeunes
sur Louis de Funès
et qui lui posent à lui.
-M. De Funès,
croyez-vous au ovni ?
-Pense bien que j'y crois !
-Depuis combien d'années
vous pratiquez ce métier ?
-Ca fait longtemps.
Ca fait déjà 35 ans.
-Avez-vous le trac
en tournant les films ?
-Bien sûr.
Tu ne l'aurais pas, toi ?
-Oui.
-Combien de films
avez-vous tourné ?
-J'ai dû tourné dans 200 films.
Mais j'ai fais des films
où j'ouvrais une porte
et je la refermais.
Des fois je la refermais pas.
J'avais un jour à faire,
1 heure ou 2 heures à faire.
Ca, ça a duré longtemps.
-C'est difficile
de faire un film ?
-Oui, car il faut au moins 70, 80
ou 100 techniciens qui sont autour.
Il y a la caméra, les ouvriers...
C'est très difficile.
-Ca coûte cher de fabriquer
une soucoupe volante ?
-Je n'en sais rien,
je ne sais pas qui l'a payée.
-Etes-vous aussi comique
dans la vie que sur l'écran ?
-Pas du tout.
Il paraît que je ne suis
pas drôle du tout.
[Les enfants répondent "si"]
-Est-ce que c'est dur de se mettre
dans la peau d'un personnage ?
-Ca dépend quel personnage.
-Celui de "La Soupe aux choux" ?
-Non, ça n'a pas été difficile.
Ca... Non, ça n'a pas été difficile.
Mais c'est difficile à jouer,
car on a tourné pendant 14 semaines,
et j'ai appris à marcher en sabots.
Et c'est très difficile.
J'arrivais à courir sur
des gros cailloux avec des sabots.
Ca n'a plus de rapport avec "Le
Gendarme et les extraterrestres",
c'est une chose
un peu philosophique.
C'est le problème
de 2 personnes âgées,
c'est-à-dire moi et Carmet,
on a près de 70 ans tous les deux,
et on a peur d'aller à l'hospice,
et je vous en raconte pas plus.
-Est-ce que les trucages
du film sont difficiles ?
-Oui, ils sont très compliqués.
Ce sont des techniciens
très qualifiés pour le faire.
Par exemple, cette soucoupe
que vous voyez,
vous allez la voir maintenant,
elle vient de là-haut,
et elle atterrit.
Et dans le film,
elle décolle aussi.
Et il y aura un autre
énorme vaisseau
qui va emmener des maisons
et un hectare de terre.